[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend sportliches hat später
wieder Christian Otto und drei
Weltmeisterinnen habe ich dabei guten
Abend und hier sind unsere Themen an
diesem Donnerstag
49 Euro Ticket im Nahverkehr der Bund
wills die Länder auch nur bei der
Finanzierung haperts noch
Schutzschild über Europa mit gemeinsamen
Abwehrsystemen wollen Deutschland und 14
Partnerländer sich vor möglichen
Angriffen aus der Luft wappnen
und so kann es weitergehen zum Auftakt
der Bahnrad WM holen die deutschen
Frauen Gold im Teamsprint und sind
hungrig auf mehr
[Musik]
gesucht wird ein Nachfolger für den
Sommerhit des Jahres namens neun Euro
Ticket immerhin die Verkehrsminister von
Bund und Ländern haben sich jetzt auf
ein 49 euro-ticket verständigt mit dem
man schon im Januar starten könnte
allerdings gibt es einen Haken es geht
ums Geld über Pläne und offene Fragen
kein niklash aus Bremen
das 9 Euro Ticket eine Erfolgsgeschichte
soll nun seine Fortsetzung finden die
Verkehrsminister des Bundes und der
Länder werteten die Nachfolgelösung als
eine der größten Reformen in der
deutschen Verkehrspolitik
wir denken dass dieses 49 Euro Ticket
wirklich für viele Menschen gerade für
viele Pendlerinnen und Pendler eine
wirkliche Entlastung mit sich bringt das
ist das was die Menschen direkt an Ihrem
Portemonnaie am Ende des Monats auch
spüren könnt das digitale Ticket soll 49
Euro kosten monatlich kündbar sein und
zum ersten Januar 2023 kommen Bund und
Länder wollen sich die Kosten dafür
Teilen Fahrgäste begrüßen das Ergebnis
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall 50 Euro ist zwar nicht so
gut wie 9 Euro Ticket aber wenn man
durch ganz Deutschland touren kann
sollte man unbedingt ausprobieren das
ist mir zu teuer weil ich nicht so oft
mit dem Bus fahre also da vielleicht
wäre es immer nutzt ist das ja
vielleicht ganz gut die Verkehrsminister
der Bundesländer wollen das Ticket
allerdings nur auf den Weg bringen wenn
der Bund beim nächsten Treffen mit den
Ministerpräsidenten Zusagen für mehr
Geld für Busse und Bahn und ein besseres
Verkehrsnetz auf dem Land einhält
der Bund hat deswegen die Initiative
ergriffen und gesagt wir sind bereit 1,5
Milliarden auf den Tisch zu legen um
eine Nachfolge Lösung zu erarbeiten
jetzt musste geklärt werden wie sie zu
eine solche Lösung technisch aus und
neben dieser Frage gibt es auch noch
weitere Fragen die die Länder geklärt
haben müssen die Finanzierungslücke über
die sich die Ministerpräsidenten mit dem
Bund verständigen müssen beträgt rund 3
Milliarden Euro auch um etwa gestiegene
Energiekosten aufzufangen
bezahlbare Busse und Bahnen sind es eine
aber Menschen die weniger Geld haben
fragen sich ganz besonders wie kann ich
bloß wie soll ich bloß den ganzen Rest
in Zeiten massiver Preisanstiege
Schultern genau damit beschäftigt ihr
sich heute auch der Bundestag neben dem
neuen geplanten Bürgergeld das ja Hartz
IV ablösen soll ging es um energiehilfen
für Rentnerinnen und Rentner und die
Erhöhung des wohnungsgeldes die anderen
Zimmermann berichtet
Bürokauffrau Ivanka wohnt mit ihren drei
Kindern in Deggendorf obwohl die
alleinerziehende Vollzeit arbeitet hat
sie für ihre Dreizimmerwohnung Anspruch
auf 80 Euro Wohngeld doch diesen Herbst
kommt sie auch damit nicht weiter
Stromkosten Heizkosten alles erhöht sich
aber der Gehalt bleibt gleich damit in
der Krise nicht zigtausende Bürger ihr
Dach über dem Kopf verlieren will die
Regierung das Wohngeld aufstocken im
Durchschnitt von 177 auf 370 Euro und
statt an bisher 600.000 Haushalte soll
es ab Januar an zwei Millionen Haushalte
ausbezahlt werden außerdem erhalten
Wohngeldbezieher 345 Euro als weiteren
Heizkostenzuschuss die zuständige
Ministerin nennt das Reformpaket
historisch es erreicht somit exakt
diejenigen die es am geringsten brauchen
darunter viele Alleinerziehende Menschen
und das ist mir auch wichtig
Rentnerinnen und Rentner sind fast die
Hälfte der wohngeldbeziehenden Haushalte
und Familien mit geringen Einkommen so
wie Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner von alten
und Pflegeheimen nichts als Kosmetik und
bei weitem nicht genug schimpft die
Linke zumal das Problem die ungezügelten
Mieten im Land sein die Christdemokraten
bemängeln dass die Regierung den
Schwerpunkt der Hilfe auf
Geringverdiener lege was sollen
eigentlich all diejenigen die arbeiten
gehen und keinen Wohngeld und keinen
Heizkostenzuschuss erhalten jetzt tun
auch die Unterstützung für die
arbeitende Mitte ist jetzt notwendiger
denn je beim Sozialverband VdK sorgt man
sich vor allem um die Umsetzung die
größte Herausforderung wird wohl liegen
vom entrock bis zur Bewilligung ob die
Landratsämter des personell so schnell
stemmen können
auch Ivanka soll im kommenden Jahr mehr
Hilfe bekommen sie hofft dass es dann
vielleicht wieder für einen Urlaub
reicht
ja viel wird also gerade über
Entlastungen debattiert nötig werden sie
im Wesentlichen weil die Inflationsrate
laut Statistischem Bundesamt wie jetzt
bekannt gegeben bei 10% liegt und damit
so hoch wie seit 70 Jahren nicht
gegenüber dem September 2021 verteuerten
sich besonders Energie um
43,9% und Nahrungsmittel um 18,7 Prozent
die Lebenshaltungskosten sind die
derzeit größte Sorge der deutschen aber
bei weitem nicht die einzige Henriette
de Maiziere und Carsten Behrendt
berichten
die Friedrichstraße im Zentrum Berlins
welche Sorgen beschäftigen die Menschen
hier
wie Energiepreise ja das ist die größte
Angst die die man uns ja macht ja unser
Stromanbieter bis November wir warten
jeden Tag ganz heiß es ist Mitte Oktober
ja was kommt da dritter Weltkrieg das
ist meine Hauptangst im Moment Umwelt
und ich mache mir eher Angst darum dass
die Menschen nicht wandlungsbereit sind
insgesamt haben die Sorgen der deutschen
zugenommen so eine Studie im Auftrag
einer großen Versicherung die aktuell
größten Ängste der deutschen steigende
Lebenshaltungskosten gefolgt von
unbezahlbarem wohnen und die Angst vor
einer schlechteren Wirtschaftslage es
sagt uns dass die Leute vor allem um
Fragen die das liebe Geld betreffen
besonders besorgt sind und eine weitere
Angst hat ja einen steilen Anstieg das
ist die Befürchtung Deutschland würde
sich in einen Krieg verwickeln trotz der
gestiegenen Kriegsangst beschäftigen
andere Sorgen die Menschen noch immer
mehr etwa Naturkatastrophen der
Klimawandel eine mögliche Überforderung
bei der Aufnahme von geflüchteten oder
die Angst vor einer Überforderung der
Politik
diese Ängste sind erstmal real sie sind
da also sollten wir sie auch wahrnehmen
und gleichzeitig aber auch den Blick
dafür schärfen was es in unserem Alltag
gibt was angenehm ist was keine Angst
verursacht und die Zuversicht im Alltag
sichern das hilft eine positive
Erkenntnis der Studie trotz aller Krisen
und Unsicherheiten ist der sogenannte
angstindex der Durchschnitt aller
abgefragten sorgen nur um 6% gestiegen
jetzt also doch die Frist zur Abgabe der
grundsteuererklärung wird um drei Monate
verlängert von Ende Oktober auf Ende
Januar 2023 das haben die Finanzminister
der Länder entschieden vor einer Woche
hieß es bis jetzt habe nicht einmal
jeder dritte Haus und Wohnungsbesitzer
die Erklärung abgegeben zu Corona
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
die Länder aufgefordert eine
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen zu prüfen
das sei wegen der hohen Infektionszahlen
sinnvoll die bisherigen Maßnahmen würden
langfristig nicht reichen die
Krankenhäuser in Deutschland seien zum
Teil schon an der überlastungsgrenze
das was Kanzler Scholz vor sechs Wochen
bei seiner europarede in Prag angestoßen
hat nimmt jetzt Gestalt an als Antwort
auf Putins Angriffskrieg will
Deutschland gemeinsam mit 14 Partnern
eine europäische Luftverteidigung
aufbauen eine entsprechende Erklärung
wurde heute am Rande des nato-treffens
in Brüssel unterzeichnet wie die Pläne
Aussehen wer sich beteiligt und welche
Fragezeichen ist dazu noch gibt Florian
neu an
einmal als erste kommen heute früh kurz
nach acht im NATO-Hauptquartier eine
ungewohnte Rolle Deutschland führt eine
neue Initiative zur Verteidigung des
europäischen Luftraums und die deutsche
Ministerin will ihren Stolz gar nicht
verbergen über
mittlerweile 15 Staaten die gemeinsam
diese Anstrengungen angehen wollen in
Bezug auf die Luftverteidigung die
Lücken zu schließen und ich freue mich
sehr dass diese Initiative dieses
European Sky Shield was Deutschland
angestoßen hat dass die auf so viel
Unterstützung gestoßen ist
European Sky Shield eine europäische
raketenschutzschild das ist die Idee
nach dem Russlands Krieg die
Sicherheitslage in Europa verändert hat
neben Deutschland wollen 13
nato-allierte mitmachen darunter
Großbritannien und mehrere
osteuropäische Staaten dazu der
nato-anwärter Finnland nicht dabei
Frankreich das auf die eigene nukleare
Abschreckung setzt und Polen alle
anderen wollen nun gemeinsam neue
Waffensysteme Einkaufen ein Favorit der
Bundeswehr das us-israelische System
Arrow 3 das Raketen sogar im Weltraum
zerstören kann
diese neuen Mittel könnten sich nahtlos
in die Raketen für den NATO einfügen und
sie würden unsere Fähigkeit als Bündnis
gegen alle Bedrohungen aus der Luft zu
verteidigen erheblich verbessern das
Deutschland ein Defizit hat bei der
Verteidigung des Luftraums das ist hier
im NATO-Hauptquartier seit Jahren
bekannt doch er ist Russlands Angriff
auf die Ukraine lässt die
Bundesregierung jetzt handeln viele
fragen sich hier nur ob Berlin bereit
ist auch finanziell die Führung zu
übernehmen wer wie viel trägt ist aber
noch unklar ebenso wie viel das alles
überhaupt kostet bisher ist das hier nur
eine Absichtserklärung
ein anderes Gremium dass ich mit Putins
Aggressionen Beschäftigte ist die UNO
Vollversammlung die sich überraschend
deutlich gegen Russland stellte in einer
Dringlichkeitssitzung verurteilte sie
die Annexionen in der Ukraine als
völkerrechtswidrig und erklärte sie für
ungültig
143 der 193 Mitgliedsstaaten stimmten
für eine entsprechende Resolution nur
fünf Länder dagegen 35 enthielten sich
zehn waren abwesend der Beschluss hat
eine hohe symbolische Bedeutung
völkerrechtlich ist er allerdings nicht
bindend
und auch heute hat Russlands Militär die
Luftangriffe auf die Ukraine fortgesetzt
im Raum Kiew schlugen nach ukrainischen
Angaben mehrere Geschosse in
Energieanlagen ein Berichte über das
Ausmaß der Schäden liegen nicht vor im
süd-ukrainischen nikolaye traf eine
Rakete ein fünfstöckiges Haus mindestens
zwei Bewohner starben in den Trümmern
ihrer Wohnung sechs Stunden nach dem
Angriff konnten Rettungskräfte einen
elfjährigen Jungen aus dem Schutt
befreien
die Menschheit kommt nicht voran im
Kampf gegen den Hunger das zeigt der
aktuelle Bericht der Welthungerhilfe
demnach sind 828 Millionen Menschen
unterernährt 17 Millionen mehr als im
Jahr zuvor besonders betroffen sind
immer mehr Länder in Afrika im Südsudan
zum Beispiel leiden zwei Drittel der
Bevölkerung unter Hunger eine Reportage
von Susan von Lojewski
das Bändchen zeigt Ruth akute
Unterernährung das Bändchen gehört zu
der kleinen Ader gut fünf Kilo wiegt das
neun Monate alte Mädchen viel zu wenig
ihre Oma hat sie in das kleine
Krankenhaus von tonnensch im Südsudan
gebracht Adler wäre fast verhungert
die Flut hat alles zerstört wir konnten
nichts mehr Pflanzen es gibt nichts zu
essen nicht einmal einen kleinen Löffel
von irgendetwas
die Flut trifft über 600.000 Menschen im
Südsudan seit Jahren taumelt das Land
von einer Krise in die nächste doch so
schlimm wie jetzt war es noch nie
der Südsudan erlebt die heftigste
Naturkatastrophe seiner Geschichte
anhaltende Regenfälle gehen weit über
die sonst übliche Regenzeit hinaus immer
mehr Menschen sind gezwungen ihre Häuser
zu verlassen und ihre Ernte aufzugeben
nur noch tagsüber zu ihrem Haus bewohnen
kann sie es nicht mehr alles stand unter
Wasser sie erntet die wenigen
Hirsekörner denn das ist alles was der
sechsköpfigen Familie noch geblieben ist
die meisten Pflanzen sind verfault
woher soll ich ein Stück Land bekommen
das höher liegt wir können nirgendwo
anders sehen
die die gar nichts mehr haben hoffen auf
Hilfe im Krankenhaus doch auch hier gibt
es kaum noch Medikamente kein Essen für
Erwachsene
unsere Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt wir
können hier in der Klinik nur wenige
Medikamente weitergeben die wir von
anderen Regierungen oder
Hilfsorganisationen gesponsert bekommen
haben
schon jetzt leidet mehr als die Hälfte
der Bevölkerung im Südsudan unter
Mangelernährung die Krise jetzt aber
könnte die Lage noch einmal dramatisch
verschärfen
[Musik]
diese Menschen brauchen Unterstützung
und so könnten sie helfen über das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe die
IBAN lautet
de65-100
400-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Hunger in
Afrika und dieser Angaben finden Sie
auch auf spenden.zdf.de und auf der ZDF
Textseite 8 9 0
jetzt nach Washington dort stellt der
Untersuchungsausschuss zur Attacke auf
das Kapitol in diesen Minuten neue
Ermittlungsergebnisse vor sie erinnern
sich sechster Januar 2021 radikale
trump-anhänger stürmen den kongresssitz
als dort der Wahlsieg beiden endgültig
bestätigt werden soll es kommt zu
Attacken auf das Sicherheitspersonal die
Randalierer dringend in Büros ein und in
den geräumten Senatssaal fünf Menschen
sterben
und wir gehen jetzt live nach Washington
zu Elma teven Elmar wie brisant ist das
was da heute an Ergebnissen präsentiert
wird
ja der Untersuchungsausschuss will heute
neue Beweise vorlegen dass das was am 6
Januar 21 passiert ist eine Plan
entsprach in den Donald Trump direkt und
indirekt in jedem Schritt involviert war
das haben die beiden Vorsitzenden von
der republikanischen und demokratischen
Partei jetzt vorhin hier in Washington
gesagt diese Beweise sind unter anderem
1,5 Millionen Dokumente E-Mail-Verkehr
andere Kommunikation des Secret Service
von eben jenem 6 Januar die belegen dass
man wusste dass auch Donald Trump wusste
dass es bewaffnete gab bei seinen
Veranstaltungen dass die planten das
Kapitol zu stürmen das zu dem Zeitpunkt
als seine Rede endete er auch wusste das
schon Gewalt angewendet wurde und er
trotzdem unbedingt zum Capitol wollte
der Secret Service hat das verhindert
indem er diesen Befehl von Donald Trump
verweigert hat es geht heute auch darum
ob der Kongress tatsächlich dem
Justizministerium empfehlen versucht
gegen Donald Trump Anklage wegen
verschiedener Straftaten darunter der
Verhinderung des Wahlprozesses Anklage
zu erheben das muss der Kongress heute
entscheiden oder dieser Ausschuss man
will darüber abstimmen und das ist
deshalb wichtig weil Donald Trump
darüber nachdenkt zur nächsten
Präsidentschaftswahl 2024 wieder
anzutreten danke nach Washington Elmar
thevissen und mehr zum
Untersuchungsausschuss und zum Kapitol
Sturm gibt es um 20 Uhr dann berichtet
ZDF heute live und zu sehen ist dass
dann in der ZDF heute App bzw auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen
jetzt geht sportlich weiter Kristin
Fußball Champions League drei Vereine
einer war erfolgreich und der heißt
Bayern genau Frankfurt Leverkusen
verdauen noch ihre Niederlagen dem
Rekordmeister reicht dagegen eine prima
erste Halbzeit um unangetastet und
vorzeitig im Achtelfinale zu stehen die
Bayern top in dieser schwierigen Gruppe
mit dem FC Barcelona und Inter Mailand
Außenseiter Viktoria Pilsen ist nach dem
2:4 ausgeschieden
die Bayern in weiß und in Spiellaune
sadio mané eröffnet nach 10 Minuten
Thomas Müller legt nach vier Minuten
später da steht's 20 und Leon Goretzka
trifft auch noch zweimal 25 und später
35 Minute mit der 4.0 Halbzeitführung in
Pilsen zeigen die Bayern ein ganz
anderes Gesicht als zuletzt in der
Bundesliga unsere chancenstatistik ist
einfach außergewöhnlich nach wie vor
auch im Europa-Vergleich haben wir
unfassbar viele Torchancen
manchmal wie heute treffen wir dann
vierfach und dann geht's ein bisschen
leichter von der Hand wie in anderen
Spielen mit Paul Wanner kommt dann
erstmals noch ein 16-Jähriger bei Bayern
in der Champions League zum Einsatz sie
lassen noch zwei Gegentore zu aber da
ist das Spiel schon abgehakt am Sonntag
kriegen die Bayern Besuch vom SC
Freiburg zum Bundesligaspiel
Weltklasse bleiben die deutschen
bahnradfahrerinnen um immer Hinze zum
Auftakt der Weltmeisterschaften auf der
Olympiabahn von Paris 24 raste das Trio
im Teamsprint erneut zu Gold sportlich
eine mega-
eine Nacht geschlafen doch auch am Tag
danach sind sie präsent die Bilder vom
großen Triumph überglückliche deutsche
Titelverteidigerinnen nach ihrer
weltrekordshow auf der Olympiabahn von
Paris gewannen Pauline Grabosch
immerhinze und Lea Sophie Friedrich
ihren dritten Titel nacheinander
eindrucksvoll aber nicht nur der Sieg
sondern auch die Zeit im Finale gegen
chancenlose Chinese nennen
45,967 Sekunden damit konnte das Trio
den eigenen Weltrekord aus dem
Halbfinale noch einmal verbessern ich
bin sehr stolz darauf was wir erreicht
haben dass jetzt einmal Weltrekord
gefahren sind und wie wir als Team
zusammengearbeitet haben nach dem
Traumstart geht die goldmission für die
deutschen Weltmeisterinnen weiter heute
ist in Paris bereits der Einzelsprint
dran
und noch eine WM-Medaille Bronze für das
deutsche Judo mix-team in Taschkent
Männer und Frauen kann nicht genug
Medaille geben Dankeschön zum Schluss
noch ein Blick in die Zukunft die wie
immer ungewiss ist die europäische
Weltraumorganisation denkt gerade über
Solarenergie aus dem All nach die könnte
von Satelliten mit großen Photovoltaik
Modulen eingefangen und dann in Form von
Mikrowellen zu Erde zurückgeschickt
werden und dort würden die Wellen dann
wieder in Strom umgewandelt im November
soll die Politik dann beraten ob das
Projekt weiter verfolgt wird
klingt sehr abgefahren zurück zur Erde
hier herbstlich trüb und regnerisch
Einzelheiten hat Katja Horne Vergleich
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
ab 21 Uhr im heute-journal Interview mit
Christian Sievers wir von der heute 19
sagen Danke morgen an dieser Stelle Jana
pareigis schönen Abend und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend Übergangsjahreszeiten heißen
Übergangsjahreszeiten weil da so viel
möglich ist da kann das kräftige
Regenfälle geben auch mal Schnee zum
Beispiel den Alpen oder auch in den
norwegischen Bergen da kommen Tiefs
heran es kann aber auch mal für viel
Sonne und Wärme reichen jetzt in der
Nacht fällt in Süddeutschland erstmal
Regen und an den Alpen sind auch
Gewitter möglich an der Ostseeküste sind
auch einige Schauer unterwegs unter den
dichteren Wolken bleibt diese Nacht aber
viel milder als die vergangenen wir
erwarten zwölf Rad am Oberrhein und fünf
Grad in der Uckermark die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 13 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein
und 19 Grad in Oberbayern und das wird
ein eher drüber Freitag besonders am
Nachmittag kann es dann hier im Westen
und dem Südwesten auch mal kräftiger
regnen Sonnenschein gibt es aber auch im
Osten das werden vielleicht so zwei bis
vier Sonnenstunden sonst ist die
sonnenausbeute eher mau das wird sich
aber schon über das Wochenende ändern
und am Montag Netzwerk erwarten wir dann
wieder verbreitet vier bis neun
Sonnenstunden sie merken daran auch dass
es auch wärmer wird nach einem
wechselhaften Samstag kommt schon am
Sonntag die Sonne häufiger zum Vorschein
am Montag gibt es dann bis zu 26 Grad
guten Abend